let's do it
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
good morning after the death of Superman
violence acts of war and terrorism are
all on the rise I had a dream
and was the end of the world
I think it's something more something
darker
we're asking people we done now to risk
their lives strong man and strong us
alone never heard that it's not saying
that's the opposite of what the saying
is
devided that we are not enough
[Music]
more on the Superman
I made him a promise
why I brought you together
ride ain't over yet man
[Music]
Oh awesome as a bad thing oh that's your
oh sorry
it's your signal that means we have to
go now yeah it's so cool
hey everybody new Justice League trailer
Superman is back and there is a new
round of Justice League ticket giveaways
- all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video if you didn't spot it they also
released an alternate version of this
with some slightly different footage so
because I don't want to do a completely
separate trailer video for that here it
is maybe you need us how do you know
you're team strong
strong man as strong as the lone never
heard that it's not saying that's the
opposite of what the saying is
this is the only way
the five of us
so I love the way they opened this with
the reveal that Superman is back until
he is not when she wakes up in bed I'll
take that as a yes remember he was going
to ask her to marry him at the end of
Batman V Superman so Martha gave her the
ring and it hasn't been as long as it
seems like I know it's been a while
since Batman vs Superman came out but I
think it's only been about six months in
the movie maybe less than a year but
they want all this stuff to devolve into
crazy town Darkseid apocalypse before he
comes back that's why the Justice League
has to assemble together why they say
you know we can't do this alone
I love Aquaman saying too strong men's
standalone and Batman it's like no
that's not even close to what the saying
is it's the opposite of that the color
tones are great you can tell if they
polish the CG a lot too so Zack Snyder
is always really good with color and
they do this thing with the socks who
they use a completely different sound
track but they open it with the Man of
Steel soundtrack at the beginning when
he's standing in that field they kind of
did that with the last trailer where
they remix the song just a little bit to
make a little more hardcore this one is
just straight-up Man of Steel at the
beginning just heralding his return but
the interesting thing that they do at
the beginning here is that they show
Steppenwolf coming for what looks like
Amazon's in this big field here and this
is where this giant battle scene has
been taking place and all the trailers
that we've seen so far but then you get
the close-up shot of what looks like a
Roman soldier so it actually seems like
because this is the Amazons either
they're on famous Kira
when this happens or they're somewhere
on the mainland and this is taking place
in the distant past like Batman tells
Wonder Woman about his dream and
everybody sort of has this vision of the
apocalypse
so the vision that he's talking about is
probably the one from Batman V Superman
the nightmare sequence but because the
three mother boxes were left on earth
thousands of years ago this is probably
when that event happened like they talk
about the Age of Heroes coming again and
when a woman's like I never thought that
it would come again this is probably
what she's talking about this older age
of Heroes most of you probably picked up
on this too this is a shot of one of
those ancient Roman soldiers or someone
else being turned into a para demon they
actually did a version of that during
the Justice League warm
which is sort of an origin story for the
new 52 Justice League where darkside
invades deserts converting a bunch of
Earth's people into parademons it's much
more efficient that way like you don't
have to bring that big of a force
because as you start defeating people
like on Game of Thrones the army of the
Dead grows exponentially as you kill
more people but you actually do get a
better look at Steppenwolf as Wonder
Woman's going up against him when
they're doing that sequence where they
all try to go up against him by
themselves and get their asses kicked
the real minor changed that they made to
his backstory for the movie is that he
is now Darkseid's nephew not the other
way around way back in the Jack Kirby
comics he was the uncle darkside was the
nephew this is a much better shot of
Batman's flying fox it's just hard to
tell the scale because they haven't
opened the door to walk out the back yet
but it's huge he has his Batmobile
inside here and then obviously you see
Steppenwolf's giant structure that he
starts constructing the minute he hits
earth so then you get to the part of the
trailer where they actually start
working together and it starts getting
more fun Aquaman gets picked up by
cyborg mid-air and thrown the cool thing
about this is that some of these
characters are so powerful that you
could actually do that you could throw
Aquaman like a football and you wouldn't
hurt him that much which is why they get
to have a little bit more fun like
imagine a version of the fastball
special where Superman throws Wonder
Woman at someone else with her sword the
reason why you don't see them doing
stuff like that is because both of them
on their own are so powerful that it'd
be incredibly redundant it was kind of
hard to tell from the earlier trailers
but now with this extra footage you get
more context so there are a bunch of
locations that they visit and try to
take down in the movie so like this is
happening in a slightly different place
than this is giant dome that the flying
fox is approaching so the idea is is
that this is happening all over the
earth like you see Aquaman getting his
ass kicked in Atlantis when they come
for that mother box so the whole idea
here is the darkside is tasked
steppenwolf with getting the three
mother boxes and they confirm that the
third one the human mother box is
actually part of cyborg now I know it
was a little bit of confusion as to the
last trailer but there was some language
and some of the marketing where it was
basically like yeah part of the thing
that they want is now part of one of the
people that is in the Justice League so
it's a bit like vision in
mine Jim you can only get it by
completely dismantling this other person
so as is a lot of narratives and big
movies like this you know typically the
villain comes right up to the brink of
achieving his goal or he achieves it and
then something happens like Superman
comes back and they defeat him but I
think that's kind of the idea is that
they need to unite everybody including
Superman and they can't defeat him until
they do so that's why Steppenwolf is so
over a competent because he's like you
don't have any Kryptonians you don't
have any lanterns so there's nothing you
can do to stop me
like even all of them together as you
see him in the trailer here but Porsche
Superman comes back or really badass
there's nothing that they can do but let
me know in the comments how bad do you
think that it's going to get for them
before Superman comes back they all
rally and finally take him down the only
thing that I think that they've changed
about the ending like there's been a lot
of reports about how they made some
edits to the way the film ends I think
that they've minimized Darkseid a little
bit because I think the idea was is that
day to beat Steppenwolf but Darkseid
still needs the mother boxes so he shows
up and says you're all royally screwed
now and that sort of opens the door for
a Green Lantern and more people to show
up during the second Justice League
movie but because they pulled back a
little bit on the world-building in the
DC EU I think we'll still see some
Darkseid related stuff happening but
they'll still leave that up in the air
in case they want to change anything
before they make that next movie and if
you're wondering there will be another
Justice League movie but they have so
many other spin-off movies like the next
Wonder Woman movie the Aquaman movie
whatever the next Man of Steel movie is
gonna look like the Batman franchise the
flashpoint movie that they want to focus
on those first before they do another
Justice League team-up favorite line
from the trailer aside from all the
Superman stuff at the beginning is the
fact that the flash is just so excited
at the sight of Batman signal it sort of
calls him out as Batman without
realizing that Wonder Woman already
knows that Bruce Wayne is Batman so
she's like yeah haha yeah I know I know
who he is I know he's the Batman yeah we
have to go but let me know what's your
favorite part of this what do you think
about the Superman twist like oh he's
back until he's not he's really just a
hallucination at this point but clearly
he's coming back they keep having
visions of apocalypse maybe Lois at the
same time will keep having visions of
Superman and that's how we'll see
earlier in the film but if you're
wondering how Superman can't come back
solar radiation actually does penetrate
down into the earth just at a much
slower rate than if he were just sitting
outside on the pavement but we'll see
how he actually winds up showing up in
the movie I'm just expecting them to
turn around and for him to be there like
after Lois has a couple more
hallucinations like wow I keep having
visions of him but not exactly like it
is in Lois's visions but if you guys
didn't know there's gonna be a new Star
Wars trailer tomorrow night so I'll post
that video after it drops also be
posting some new Rick and Morty there'll
be some Game of Thrones later tonight
too so whole bunch of stuff happening
congratulations to jorge de Ocampo
you're the latest ticket giveaway winner
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
brand new flash and you can click here
for a brand new Thor and infinity war
thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight